what do you make of this OIC OIC seems
like it's avoiding the big issue well to
me it's all about uh hard work you know
that's why I say in in in my book you
know work work your ass off and because
it's there's no shortcut and you have to
kind of put the work in and you know I
talked earlier about the bicep the more
you kind of torture the bicep you know
the more resistance you give it and the
more pain there is the more it grows
the same is with us with with the human
man mind the human mind can only really
grow through resistance you can only
strengthen your character and become a
really strong person inside if you have
resistance if you fail if you get up
again and if you work hard and if you
work your ass off and if you struggle
the more you struggle the further you're
going to go and the stronger you're
going to get so this just the the the
way the rule Works anyone that tries to
Baby themselves
and pamper themselves and trying to
protect themselves oh I don't want to
feel bad or I don't really want to go
through any discomforted it's over
you're never going to get there that's
just the way it is I mean you have to be
able to struggle and if you're not able
to work on that work on that that you're
learning how to uh accept pain misery
and discomfort all the things that you
don't like because the more you
experience the things that you really
don't like the more you can grow and the
tougher you get and the more you can
handle I mean it's just that simple so
many young kids today kind of shy away
from that but you have to be attracted
to that uh just think about and I talk
about that in the book I mean what built
this
country what built this country is it
people that slept
in is it people that were wimping out
that says I want to feel good I want to
be comfor no this were ballsy women and
men that went out there at 5:00 in the
morning and got up and they struggled
and they fought and they worked their
butts off that's what made this country
great and so now let's continue this way
don't start creating a generation of
wimps and weak people and stuff like
that where we go into be are concerned
about how are you feeling today oh I
don't want to hurt your feelings and
also it's nice to be considerate yes I
totally agree with that but let's not
over baby the kids and let's not over
baby kind of the people I mean let's go
and teach kids to be tough to go out and
do Sports to go and study to struggle
and you know to go through this kind of
painful moment
sometimes